Michael how common is it for
documentarians to work on more than one
documentary at a time to be Polly
documentarian a mini daya it's very very
common i would assume i'm not sure if
I'm the best person because I kind of go
my own way but from people I know in the
documentary field they're gonna be
working on mini-documentaries at a time
two or three even probably because it
takes so long to do them and you're not
always you know you're not filming for
to you know you're filming hey we're
going to come here to for this event
that happens and we're going to see you
in three months and all that so you have
time to work on other stuff so in my
personal experience I I work on i'm
working on three at the moment and will
probably start shooting another one
hopefully in May so we'll have like four
going and yeah so it's it's pretty
common obviously I think a lot of people
who shoot documentaries they shoot one
documentary they're just kinda they're
seeing if they like the field if they
like the field I mean a lot of people
were like I've been doing it for a
couple years and then they'll set you
know they have two or three they're
doing instead of just the one they were
doing
you